greetings everyone a kiss on both cheeks
and here's a 20 for that thing you took
care of that time today on the show it's
a familial fracas featuring four voting
fathers whose families hail from the old
world and are now staking their claim on
america and in the world of film and
television because we have an all-time
mob mayhem matchup it's the godfather
trilogy going up against the soprano
series in this episode of verses
in one corner you have the corleone
family and their gaggle of royal
denizens and hangers on in the other
corner it's a soprano clan and their
flock of goodfellas nerd due wells and
mental health experts so you may already
be thinking but mark you handsome
bastard how can we accurately compare a
classic movie trilogy to a beloved tv
series don't worry if it seems like
we're comparing apples to oranges
remember that oranges are vito's
favorite fruit until you know that thing
that happened here's how we'll determine
a winner round one box office slash
ratings round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three best
characters round four iconic moments and
then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve which family i'd rather
spend a holiday with or whose daughter's
wedding i'd rather attend the godfather
is making its debut on verses although
those first two films were probably the
mvp when the 1970s won the best picture
decade episode meanwhile the sopranos is
looking to rebound after losing a
nailbiter to breaking bad last season
and when a guy like tony soprano is
seeking revenge it's best to um yeah i
might not have much time left so let's
get it on round one box office slash
ratings and here we have the ultimate
conundrum when comparing pop tarts to
applejacks two totally different metrics
are utilized to calculate who was
watching what at the movies or at home
and while the sopranos will be hoping
that the ratings during its run are
looking sharp the godfather is hoping to
attract some eye-popping ticket receipts
it's obviously not going to be an exact
science but that's why i'm here i took
ap chemistry in high school how'd i do
sorry that's family business only so
let's just see if immediately anything
is gonna stand out and i see a rather
large number i also took ap calculus and
that would be the one billion dollars
generated by the three godfather films
the 1970s may have not featured as much
competition week to week as we see now
but also keep in mind that the price of
a ticket back then was i don't know what
35 cents a dollar i think you could also
just sing a jaunty tune at the box
office window and they'd let you in the
lion's share of godfather coin is thanks
to the og part one which did
722 million dollars during its lengthy
run curiously the godfather two's take
was a far cry from its predecessor
hauling in a still healthy 232 million
dollars so we added a de niro and we
still shed 500 million dollars of weight
okay well how do we do an andy garcia
and sophia coppola joined the party a
couple decades later even less dollars
but for all the stigma surrounding that
third installment it still grossed 145
million bucks which brings the entire
trilogy's total to
1.099 billion that's so much cheddar we
don't even meddle in the drug
trafficking trade right michael the
sopranos has a sizable task ahead of it
how do you beat that kind of dough with
ratings well remember this by the time
the tony murder variety show debuted on
hbo in january of 1999 viewers already
had plenty of options on what to watch
so how did the sopranos do amidst a sea
of entertainment on the small screen
okay well to start its lowest season is
its first one which clocked about 3.5
million viewers per episode but that
word of mouth is a tricky thing and as
the show racked up accolades so too did
its rating numbers 7.6 million folks
tuned into the season 2 opener and
throughout that entire year the sopranos
held strong notching an average of 6.62
gawkers in millions per episode and if
you think that's impressive just wait
another season season three debut to the
all-time highest number for any one
sopranos episode ever at a ridiculous 22
million viewers which is roughly 44
million eyeballs hoping for yet another
gloriously devious season season 4 is
the record holder for most average
viewers as almost 11 million people were
on board each and every week and the
final two seasons would hover around 8.5
million viewers on average and that
highly debated series finale caught the
interest of nearly 12 million folks one
of whom was me who had never seen the
show at the time and immediately rooted
for tony thanks to our shared love of
journey if you think that the box office
take and the ratings total should go
their separate ways
yet it's a it's a journey song then
maybe you're right but these two
franchises are linked in another more
curious way after that series finale
abruptly cut to black every cable
company in america was flooded with
angry phone calls from fans who thought
their cable cut out at the worst
possible time the ending of the sopranos
well it turns out that was the ending of
the sopranos but i still imagine some
cords were permanently cut that evening
meanwhile the godfather also has an
impressive television feat on its resume
in 1974 the film made its small screen
debut on nbc hey that's us that's we're
all in this together and get this as
soon as the broadcast ended new york
city saw a huge spike in toilet flushes
that resulted in several flooding issues
everyone was glued to their tv during
the godfather and they held it in until
the closing credits i gotta assume some
of those folks also just wanted to see
you know if any weaponry was hidden in
their private throne rooms like in the
movie it's kind of a big plot point in
that flick and now i have to award this
round to someone but i'm not gonna make
it easy on myself by saying well the
sopranos was easier to watch because you
didn't have to leave the house it's not
that people had to make more of an
effort to go out and see the godfather
movies it's the sheer amount of humanity
that made the theater trip again and
again and again and then watched it at
home while their bladder slowly expanded
aren't you glad you can just now pause
tv when nature calls a billion dollars
spawned from the 70s to the early 90s is
no joke and it makes all the difference
here the godfather plunges its way to a
win and has an early lead one to nothing
i'm a little depressed
round two tomato meter slash audience
score aha finally around where the
things might get a tad bit more balanced
as the beloved tomato meter and its pal
the audience score are reliable metrics
for movies tv and some short flicks like
2020s the godfather coda which weighs in
on the tomato meter at 87 percent
speaking of which that happens to be the
average for all three films in the
corleone franchise
and if 87 sounds a little bit low
there's a reason and you already know
what it is it's an elephant in the room
and said creature is named the godfather
three i don't know how you compete with
the first two flicks but three is still
fresh at 68 percent which isn't bad
until you look at its big brothers the
godfather is currently 98 certified
fresh and the godfather two falls all
the way down one whole percentage point
at 97 certified fresh which begs the
question who's in the two percent of
critics that weren't smitten with veto
michael sunny and the gang that doesn't
sound like a fun click to hang out in
whoever they were they might favor the
sopranos because that show can boast two
seasons that are at a perfect 100 on the
tomato meter it's seasons one and three
for keeping score at home and the show
was comfortably coasting in the 90
percentile and above until
it didn't quite stick the landing the
first part of season six is at 89
percent and the second part of its
finale season is the low bar setter at
83 percent did i mention that not
everyone was stoned in love with that
ending
that's another journey song and it might
have a few art mostly i don't know it'll
be fun keep watching overall the
sopranos tomato meter average is a
stellar 92 percent which gives it the
lead over the godfather but now take a
gander at the audience score
and it's going to be another nail-biter
here's the bad news for tony and carmelo
soprano they have no seasons that are at
that lofty perch of 100
but now the good news none of their
seasons dipped below 97
none including the season that made a
bunch of dads yelled directv when they
were just starting that little satellite
business the sopranos is resting well
with a 98 overall average on the
audience score and the godfather has
some work to do and it's up to the task
part one is at 98 and part two is at 97
percent according to our trusty audience
score and now it all comes down to part
three which is not really a position the
godfather wanted to be in it's an even
steeper fall than it was on the tomato
meter as the godfather 3 clocks in at a
barely fresh 61
ah audiences they love the original they
love the sequel and then they kind of
fell off the horse riding into the
sunset look the ending of both these
properties are controversial to say the
least and it's going to continue to be a
factor in this matchup but for this
round it does appear that both critics
and audiences were much more forgiving
about one scene ending a wee bit early
as opposed to an entire film simply not
living up to its namesake my monday
morning quarterback advice for the
godfather 3 put in ewoks a ton of them
it worked for return of the jedi and
return of the king
what's up there's there's no ewoks in
the lord of the rings really
okay well a note to those films ewoks
make everything better and they probably
have a criminal underbelly we're getting
off track now i want to see that movie
the sopranos wins round two and we got
us a tight ball game one to one
he's a traitor
don't forget that you know sometimes
life is good
round three best characters
so we're tied after two intense rounds
thus far and when you think about how
the sopranos could possibly surge ahead
of the celebrated film franchise that
kicked off almost 20 years before tony
was even a twinkle in hbo's eye it might
be here best characters why well the
sopranos had six seasons to establish
existing players introduce new ones and
of course whack some of the folks that
needed to be um taken care of and you
have to start with james gandolfini's
masterful portrayal of tony a man who
entertainment weekly summed up rather
nicely with the king of anti-heroes tony
was a rumbling storm cloud of a man who
could shift from oafish charm to
frightening rage to heartbreaking
self-pity at the drop of a cannoli i i
get that reference but it's true and
maybe even giving him the title of
anti-hero isn't villainous enough for
all the crimes he committed on a pretty
much daily or i don't know hourly basis
but we still thought that there was good
in him that there was something worth
redeeming in that looming stormfront of
a man much of that good was on display
when it came to tony doing what he could
for his family even though his actions
caused much of the expiration warned by
tony's wife carmella played by the
equally great edie falco gandolfini and
falco each took home three emmys during
the run of the sopranos and that's in no
small way thanks to how the two
interacted with one another on screen
carm knew or at least she suspected much
of the no good that her husband was up
to but she was mostly able to keep her
emotions at bay for the good of the
soprano family and like the audience she
knew or at least hoped that the good
outweighed the bad with her husband and
pray that his angels would outlast his
demons and while i wouldn't classify his
kids as angels both metal and aj proved
to be valuable assets to the show that
didn't shy away from tough issues that
teens deal with especially if their old
man is in the mop excuse me waste
management the patriarch of the
godfather films was such a powerful
presence and had such an impact on his
family that he had to be portrayed by
not one but two oscar-winning actors
marlon brando and robert de niro won
oscars for the shared role of vito
corleone brando obviously for the
godfather and de niro for the flashbacks
of young veto in the godfather 2. the
film franchise leaves no doubt who its
title is referencing from the opening
sequence where we see vito at the peak
of his influence brando plays him note
perfect but later in the film would also
definitely handle a suddenly frair
corleone hoping to pull through after a
murder attempt in broad daylight and to
witness de niro nail the formative ears
of the character in the next film is
equally as impressive it's a shame that
we would have to wait another 20 years
to see him and pacino share another
movie and actually have a few scenes
together in 1995's heat oh hey look at
that al pacino is pretty good in these
flicks too as michael his arc in the
first film goes from a guy who keeps his
distance from the family at first but
sees an opportunity to assert his
rightful place as a successor and leans
into it even though his brother the
hot-headed sonny would appear to be the
logical choice at the film's outset
taking in when he was just a boy and
raised like a corleone robert duvall's
tom hagan proved to be an invaluable
asset to veto whose loyalty to the
familial causes was always unquestioned
in case you still weren't convinced on
how epic the godfather is consider that
james khan al pacino and robert duvall
all earn best supporting actor
nominations for the film who won
you guessed it joel gray for his role as
the mc from cabaret
pacino would go on to be nominated for
best lead actor for the godfather 2
where he lost uh it must have been a
jack nicholson in chinatown right no
okay dustin hoffman is lenny bruce huh
what's that they all lost to art carney
for henry and tonto
fair enough for what it's worth de niro
did win that night for veto which makes
the rule if you play veto you win gold
if you play anyone else in the family
you get a nomination just like when andy
garcia was nominated for his role as
vincent in the godfather 3. but the
families themselves are just the start
of the memorable characters we've had in
these two pillars of entertainment who
could forget luca brasi and clemenza
luca still suffering one of the tougher
demises in mob movie history and the
godfather two we'd also see talia shire
lee strasberg and michael v gazzo earn
best supporting nominations john cazzali
as fredo diane keaton as k and abe
vigoda as tazio are also incredible
portrayals that deepen the war of the
first two godfather films folks weren't
as kind towards sophia coppola and the
godfather three but again the movie is
still fresh it's just not super amazing
best of all time kind of fresh and if
it's fresh you want then feast your eyes
on the fashion of tony and his mafia
cronies in the sopranos we get silvio
played by steven van zandt hey did you
know bruce springsteen's guitarist is
also named steven
it's the same person that's little
stevie talk about versatility how many
of us could pull off the fun positive
vibes of glory days and then go whack
adriana like that michael imperioli as
christopher maltz asante and tony sarico
as paulie walnuts also an unforgettable
performances to the series in fact
sariko had some uh how do you say
personal experiences to rely on for his
role he was a real wise guy getting
arrested 28 times and serving 20 months
in jail and his wardrobe is just
perfect vincent pastore is big [ __ ]
andrea demeteo as adriana made us feel
so many things when their respective
characters met their fate and the
sopranos also featured dozens of great
supporting roles from folks like steve
buscemi robert patrick and joe pantliano
joey pants but while both franchises
have stars and award-winning
performances for days the sopranos was
able to take full advantage of its
length over the course of six and a half
seasons to flesh out its most valuable
contributors as impressive as the
godfather is for engaging us so deep
into this world so fast the slow burn of
the sopranos and its gradual
matriculation of character arcs is just
too powerful to ignore and one of the
key reasons for our continued sympathy
of tony is the character that he keeps
returning to week after week dr melfi
played by lorraine bronco her matching
of wits with tony as she's coaching him
through his issues reveal his inner
complexities and demons that he has and
he shares some of those with his
therapist their sessions are one of the
biggest reasons that the sopranos is a
show that can be binged and i've done it
many times but each hour is so heavy you
could also stand to take six seven days
off between each episode you know that's
how we used to have to do it kids you
just gotta wait led by james gandolfini
and edie falco's perfectly layered
portrayals it is the sopranos who sees
the lead in round three and now the
godfather finds itself trailing two to
one
what's the matter with you
i think your brain is going soft but
before we move on to round four it's
trivia time who is the only actor to
appear in both the godfather and the
sopranos franchises thanks to andre from
brad garrett's comedy club in las vegas
for this gem of trivia know-how it's
dominique gian easy he's uncle junior on
the sopranos but he was also johnny owa
and the godfather too it's a fun fact
use it on your friends all right here
comes the next round round four iconic
moments folks if you've seen any of the
godfather movies you're probably aware
that vito doesn't like being in debt to
anyone else and he hates losing but
that's the position his team currently
finds itself in as the sopranos
cacophony of characters were too much
for the three coppola films but now we
turn our eyes and ears to the moments
that made these franchises special if
you're known to be arguably the best
movie or tv show ever then yeah we got
moments some of these instances from the
sopranos actually happened in the show
but just as striking are the weird
dreams and visions that tony has all too
often whether it's a panic attack
feeding his beloved ducks in season one
or an all-out david lynchian fever dream
in season four these illuminate the
fragility of a guy who appears to be
unsinkable on the surface that buoyancy
usually arrives in the form of classic
boss toughness one of my personal faves
is when tony murders fabian while on a
college campus visit trip with his
daughter kids they grow up so fast
speaking of kills some of these whacks
hurt more than others yes we know big
[ __ ] had it coming but it was
nevertheless emotional when the fellas
took him out on the boat for one last
time and it appears to be a mission that
still haunts seasons later similarly the
brutality of this life is on full
display when adriana gets killed by
silvio in season 5. i'd also highlight
her admitting to being an fbi informant
from that very same season emotional
deaths are the centerpiece of the
godfather trilogy whether it's michael
leaving us all by himself in the
godfather 3 or it's sunny dying in the
first film or veto being gunned down at
a fruit stand the guy just wanted some
oranges but he of course was also a
known mob boss and there's no better
evidence of that than young veto in the
godfather 2 when he murders the two dons
the most emotional moment of that entire
movie however is a toss-up between the
you won't take my children's speech and
the i know it was you fredo line both
still hold up as all-time acting master
class scenes but hey even though there's
tons of killings and families being
ripped apart we can still have some fun
right one of my favorite things about
both the godfather and the sopranos are
the moments of celebration and community
even though we as an audience know that
we're eventually being set up and we're
going to see the cost of these
gatherings vito's daughter getting
married is a perfect opening that gives
us the power dynamics within and around
the curley owns not too long after we
get to hear the perfect line i'm going
to make him an offer he can't refuse
what's the offer well it's not great if
you're a jockey i'll tell you that any
day you wake up and there isn't a horse
head in your bed that's a good morning
and one of the best afternoons in the
sopranos is the curious at the time and
now classic season three episode pine
barrens in which chris and paulie get
lost in the woods we get lots of laughs
here along with some violence and that
episode was actually directed by steve
buscemi
who if you'll recall was his own little
mob boss in the film billy madison if
it's controversy you want then let's cut
to the chase the ending of the sopranos
remains one of the most talked about
finales in tv history and the debate
still rages on but for the abruptness of
what it was trying to accomplish it's a
perfect setup we enter a diner there's
not much in the way of dialogue and that
enhances the eerie feel that it's about
to go down after all the vicious murders
we'd seen in gory fashion on the show
the one we were anticipating dreading
the most isn't shown or did it ever
really happen
talk amongst yourselves for the
godfather series for me the scenes that
still resonate the most are watching
michael come into his own seeing the
loss of his own lover and the godfather
seals the lifestyle that in the back of
his mind he always knew was inevitable
and when selazo and mccluskey get shot
in the restaurant his fate is sealed as
the new corleone not to mess with we
also get the classic leave the gun take
the cannoli line that to this day might
be one of the most quoted lines in best
picture winner history it's moments of
plenty from both properties in this
round that really make it a tough call
but while the sopranos is a well-paced
serial that will slowly build up to its
legendary payoffs the first two
godfather films they play out like it's
one long great moment nothing is wasted
in storytelling and everything has a
purpose and even in re-watching the
godfather 3 it still has some punch like
when joey zaza gets killed
going back to see tony's speech to his
family from season one that sets up so
many of the events we're about to see
made this decision excruciating but the
added quotability of the godfather from
virtually every major performer in those
movies won out at the end of the day
here the godfather takes round four and
we got us a tied ball game heading into
the last round two to two don't ever
take sides with anyone against the
family again
and now it's time for the wild card
round legacy if it looks like i'm
sweating a little bit on camera it's
because i'm just imagining in my head
these two families watching me make a
decision as to who i like better i like
y'all equally it's just the
entertainment options it's a tough call
folks and you really can't tell the
story of tv without mentioning the
sopranos and the history of film would
be missing a giant piece without the
godfather the legacy of these two
legendary entities aren't even limited
to their initial mediums they've
transcended over the years to become a
part of the zeitgeist lexicon and other
big words that i have no business using
let's start with the stats these works
dominated their respective fields in the
most prestigious award categories the
sopranos has 113 wins and over 300
nominations in premium tv award circles
and the godfather was always a presence
at the oscars winning best picture for
both parts one and two and securing
seven nominations for part three but
it's the sopranos that get a leg up when
it comes to award winning as it was the
very first cable tv show to win an emmy
for most outstanding drama in 2004. that
was a watershed moment for television
and in no small part paved the way for
cable shows and eventually streaming
shows to be taken just as seriously and
in many ways surpass that of network tv
the endings do factor into legacy here
and it really is whether you prefer the
unknown quantity that is tony's demise
or the now alone michael slumping and
dying in his chair the sopranos was
certainly the one that was more talked
about particularly on myspace but that's
also because it was more controversial
and it still is almost 15 years later if
the sopranos did have an early lead in
this round then the godfather is about
to come roaring back it would be
breaking news if the godfather landed as
low as number three on any of the list
of the greatest all-time films it
currently occupies the number two slot
on both the afi and bfi lists and it was
voted as the best film in history on the
charts of entertainment weekly empire
magazine and the hollywood reporter and
a lot of people still think that
godfather 2 is even better meanwhile the
sopranos makes regular appearances in
the top five of almost every best tv
show list in fact it does top the heap
at number one on rolling stones list and
placed at number three according to
empire and number 6 for the hollywood
reporter that's of course the magazine
rolling stone and not the band the
rolling stones although i imagine they
probably appreciate the show too so
after all the awards and rankings start
to fade what are we left with what is
that intrinsic element that makes each
franchise so unique and memorable well
for the sopranos it's the pioneering
efforts in storytelling this show was
never interested in how tv could limit
it it only sought to expand what was
possible with telling a story that
involved so much emotional depth every
show that followed it from breaking bad
to lost to tiger king probably owes a
monster debt of gratitude to what david
chase brought to hbo on a weekly basis
for six and a half glorious seasons it
wasn't always consistent in terms of
pacing or tone but maybe that was the
point and bonus props should be awarded
to its embracing of mental health
awareness america saw a tough guy why
tony soprano moved mountains just to
make his weekly therapy appointments and
one has to imagine that that let
millions of people know it's all right
to ask for help in the other corner the
godfather is a tremendous story for
mario puzo but what the films did was
set the standard for greatness in terms
of movie making every quality a film
should have is what the first two
godfather films did arguably better than
any cinematic venture before or after
writing directing and acting are all on
a par with anything else that we've ever
seen at the box office the iconic lines
memorable death scenes and attention to
set detail keep this franchise aloft the
mount olympus of film and it also showed
us that yes folks it's possible for a
sequel to be just as good and maybe even
better than the original and that is
what the godfather feels like as a whole
the original the property against which
all future crime stories would be judged
sure there were tons of mob movies made
for decades before the godfather ever
existed we even now have fake old-timey
mafia movies like angels with filthy
souls in home alone it still blows my
mind that's not a real movie but forever
after the 1970s it didn't matter what
format the story was in good fellows the
sopranos and everything else had to give
it up to the og the godfather is overtly
referenced multiple times throughout the
sopranos but it's tony who can most
relate to what the film's major players
are going through he would be very
interesting in that world ooh that's an
episode i want to talk about but for
this show it's the film franchise that
takes a slight edge the godfather wins
the wild card round and thus the match
you know you're a stupid mother you know
that it's not personal sonny
it's strictly business
but there was no right or wrong decision
to make for this one of all the episodes
of verses i've ever done my extremely
informal polling came back with the most
mixed results for which of these
contenders is the best and that's the
beauty of
well beauty it's in the eye of the
beholder and here's a parting hot take
the godfather 3
is pretty good it certainly ate one or
two but i dug it more than i remember at
that ending of the sopranos it is still
surprisingly abrupt i know it's coming
but it still sneaks up on me like a
gunman in a diner but wow the attention
to detail in that final scene really
brings back so much from every season
maybe every episode of the entire show's
run okay that's my two cents now it's
your turn dear viewer which is your
favorite and why hit me up on social
media at mark ellis live with your take
and until next time
oh we're not gonna do the cut to black
joke i already did it once that's right
well okay i guess um thanks for watching
and don't stop believing unless you get
a fish in the mail because we all know
what that means i'm mark ellis and i'll
see you next time on verses
you